just want to bring you some breaking
news on the story regarding Gary lineker
and the BBC confirming that he will be
stepping down from a match of the day
for the moment they've released a
statement this evening it reads uh BBC
spokesperson saying that some of our
pundits have said that they don't wish
to appear on the program while we seek
to resolve the situation with Gary we
understand their position and we have
decided that the program will focus on
Match action without Studio presentation
or punditry so match of the day is going
ahead without any presentation
whatsoever in the studio or any pundits
in the studio and they're saying as that
statement suggests they will concentrate
on Match action so that's the very
latest on that from the BBC this evening